What we're seeing today,
is dramatic evidence of what
happens when you fail
to talk honestly about
your history.
And it harkens to the mid-
19 century
during the Civil War.
So Lincoln becomes
important to reflect
on the issues of division that
we're seeing today.
Abraham Lincoln has outwitted
just about as many historians as
politicians of his own day.
Unless you understand
what is going on
around what he is saying.
You can never really understand
Abraham Lincoln.
♪♪
Lincoln did not start
his presidency
to be the great emancipator.
It's not a phrase Lincoln asked
to be applied to himself
and we can do better.
♪♪
Frederick Douglass
is every bit the equal
of the president of the
United States.
He's constantly in Lincoln's ear
pushing him on black humanity.
As the voices that have
access to Lincoln
change Lincoln himself
changes in response.
♪♪
Lincoln's number one
agenda is unification.
It is not the
abolition of slavery.
♪♪
Lincoln was forced to
reckon with slavery
due to black people
themeselves.
He came to think that
out of this would come
something truly monumental.
Lincoln is talking about doing
something pretty radical here.
Something really important
inside of him was opening up.
He was trying to navigate
the currents of
really irreconciable ideas.
♪♪